bienvenidos a este especial la serie en
france 24 yo soy andrés meza muñoz con
materia el cambio climático es uno de
los compromisos del presidente entrante
de eeuu joe biden estará a cargo de un
país con un vacío en políticas
medioambientales heredados de donald
trump quien por ejemplo se retiró del
acuerdo de parís este camino está lleno
de desafíos
aquí abordaremos algunos de ellos el sur
de florida se ha convertido en un
epicentro de la crisis climática en eeuu
la amenaza por la subida del nivel del
mar ha provocado que muchos piensen
antes de invertir en propiedades en esta
zona del país golpeada por múltiples
huracanes nuestro corresponsal tanto
nivel si tienen los detalles
bueno es muy buen apartamento
jamie lleva más de un año intentando
vender su lujoso apartamento frente a la
bahía de miami por más de medio millón
de dólares en otra época esta propiedad
hubiese durado pocos días en el mercado
pero la amenaza de inundaciones por la
subida del nivel del mar hace que muchos
compradores pierdan interés llevo un año
tratando de vender pero frecuentemente
esta área siempre se inunda creo que va
a ser imposible encontrar a alguien que
me pueda comprar el apartamento los
pronósticos son desalentadores en un
futuro cercano esta zona podría quedar
impracticable por el cambio climático es
difícil de predecir cuándo será pero es
una realidad que en algún momento todas
estas construcciones quedarán bajo el
agua como apuntan los ambientalistas
porque estos son lugares que están muy
bajos los lugares que están altos o
están bajo el nivel del mar son todo
esto que vemos ahora puede desaparecer
eso ha provocado un creciente interés en
comprar en zonas deprimidas de la ciudad
con menos riesgo de inundación y muchas
posibilidades de transformación álvaro
que trabaja como agente inmobiliario en
el sur de la florida ha visto esta
tendencia en los últimos tiempos la
denominan gentrificación climática esto
es una zona que antiguamente se está muy
mal vista ahora gracias a todo lo que se
estaba ocurriendo con esto del cambio
climático estamos viendo también mucha
gente empezando a invertir más a las
afueras de miami estamos subiendo donde
podemos las paredes para las autoridades
de miami beach han construido varios
muros de hormigón en toda la isla y han
subido algunas calles para hacer frente
al incremento del nivel del mar pero no
es suficiente y el comisionado del área
tiene muchas esperanzas en la nueva
presidencia todos estos planes van a
costar mucho dinero más de un billón de
dólares que no tiene la ciudad de miami
beach
el nuevo presidente va a ir en un nuevo
congresista van a trabajar y ayudarnos
el presidente electo joe biden ya se ha
comprometido en incorporar políticas
medioambientales en su agenda del
próximo gobierno de eeuu si no lo hace
ahora dicen después puede ser demasiado
tarde
durante su campaña joe biden se
comprometió a reintegrarse
inmediatamente al acuerdo de parís para
liderar la lucha contra la crisis
climática en el mundo los demócratas
también incluyeron en su programa
electoral la supresión de todas las
órdenes ejecutivas de trump sobre
energía y el nuevo gobierno
estadounidense quiere impulsar una
transición hacia una economía con más
protagonismo de las energías renovables
cómo está el panorama en materia
ambiental en eeuu
hablamos con yo acá arditti rocha
directora ejecutiva del instituto clio
en miami para ahondar en la situación
el presidente baile va a heredar una
emergencia climática y los últimos años
los últimos años de la administración
del trump han dejado un gran
vacío en cuanto a temáticas de políticas
públicas ambientales más de 100
regulaciones y estándares que protegen
nuestro aire nuestra agua nuestro medio
ambiente han sido revertidas por la
administración de trump el presidente de
bailén ha prometido desde el primer día
reinstituir los eeuu al acuerdo
climático de parís para nosotros es una
fuente de gran esperanza sobre todo
viviendo en el sur de la florida
donde realmente estamos en primera fila
de tantos efectos a causa del cambio
climático
otra medida decisiva será la
implementación de energías limpias que
ayuden a cuidar al medio ambiente y que
a la vez generen empleo
la ciencia está establecida los estudios
están hechos de que invertir en energías
limpias renovables crean miles y
millones de empleos a nivel global es
uno de los de los de los sectores con
más crecimiento de empleos en los
últimos años entonces lo que tenemos es
que ver donde somos ineficientes y dejar
de seguir dando subsidios a lo que paul
huye a lo que destruye y subsidiar y
apoyar las energías limpias que no nos
afectan no solamente dejan o paul huyen
no es el aire que respiramos sino
también no desestabilizan el clima que
nosotros necesitamos para nuestro día a
día entonces buscar maneras donde
podamos reactivar la economía y crear
nuevos empleos a la misma vez mientras
vamos protegiendo nuestro clima y
mejorando el aire que respiramos y el
agua que tomamos es la manera para
seguir adelante hasta aquí la serie de
france 24 en nuestras próximas emisiones
estaremos abordando otros
le esperan a bailén en temas como
migración y economía quédense con
nosotros
[Música]